my name is saturated coach most people
call me satra I'm in the McGovern
Institute for brain research and I'm
associated with John Gabriella's lab so
the two projects I'm working on that are
directly related to the military they're
both on traumatic brain injury and in
particular mild traumatic brain injury
the reason this has become huge in the
recent years is that a large percentage
of veterans returning from the two wars
are afflicted with traumatic brain
injury the first study is a clinical
trial being conducted near Fort Hood at
the Carl are Donell medical center and
in that trial what we are trying to do
is to take people with traumatic brain
injury with or without comorbid
post-traumatic stress disorder and
trying to enhance their cognitive
attention and memory deficits what we
are hoping to get from the fort hood
study is that this approach that we are
proposing in terms of cognitive training
and real-time functional MRI that the
synthesis of those to give the maximum
benefit to the soldiers so the second
project also relates to traumatic brain
injury and that's part of a larger
project at MIT itself we're going to
bring in a group of soldiers who have
been diagnosed with mild traumatic brain
injury and corresponding controls and
run them through extensive
characterization of the structure and
function the goal is that with blast
impact there might be long-range
connections in the human brain which
might have been disrupted the brain has
never been characterized at this level
of imaging detail in the population and
we are hoping to shed a flood light on
that brain with the scanner these
studies form a facet of the picture on
traumatic brain injury and what we
really hope is that it helps us to get
more people interested in funding such
studies in being able to collaborate
across
which are doing similar studies and try
and understand and get a picture of this
disorder at a much larger scale
something that's closer to the 200,000
people who are affected I'm not trying
to do things alone I'm connecting people
people are helping me with these
projects that reduces the time I have to
spend on it while still getting the same
productive output out of a given project
yes there are times when I'll pull
all-nighters and there are times when
I'll take a break and build a chicken
coop within the context of the family
we're trying to live a very sustainable
lifestyle growing food we have chickens
and bees and we have a seven-year-old
daughter so across all of those things
that provides a completely different
perspective on life that's very
different from what I see within the
context of the lab so over the last few
years my goal has been to play the role
of a social engineer in fact most of the
time when people ask me what you do I
say I'm a social engineer and a bit part
of that is connecting up people because
while people are driving their own
unique Nicias and skill sets there is
still a problem to be solved and that
should be the focus of science is that
we are trying to understand the brain
and translate that into therapies into
applications that we could derive from
that understanding and knowledge and we
need a village essentially
you